well you know how we tap a keg yes
figure out a way to tap a volcano we've
seen quite big volcanoes on Mars and
we've got loads of volcanoes on Venus
we've recently discovered that there's
still activity today there where's the
ones on Mars are dormant yeah so we
haven't seen activity on Mars for
billions of years I think
um
very unlikely but Venus on the other
hand is is continually erupting so it's
really really active probably much more
active than Earth okay so I have a task
for Paul or you know how we tap a keg
yes figure out a way to tap a volcano
okay
so we can release the pressure so that
it doesn't blow its head okay okay